Watchmen is one of the most popular and
influential comic books ever written in
the 80s by English wizard Alan Moore
Watchmen is a superhero story that
questions the idea of a hero which is
symbolized by this bloody smiley face
the smiley is the ultimate simplistic
cartoon representing the optimism of
comic books where good guys fight bad
guys and no one ever really dies
Watchmen splashes that smiley with blood
because it adds flawed human characters
moral ambiguity politics philosophy and
darkness there was unusual in comics at
the time of course now everything's a
dark gritty reimagining of superheroes
but Watchmen did it before it was cool
and still holds up as a complex story
about power morality fantasy and giant
psychic squids so what happens in the
original Watchmen and what does it mean
the story set in an alternate 80's
America where superheroes exist none of
them have superpowers they're just
vigilantes in costumes except for dr.
Manhattan who has like all the powers
except pants with dr. Manhattan's help
America won the Vietnam War and Richard
Nixon is still president he's on his
fifth term a hero called the comedian
does dirty work for the government and
it's hinted that he covered up the
Watergate scandal which in the real
world ended Nixon's presidency
so superheroes changed the course of
history and they also affect culture the
hero Silk Spectre was a celebrity and
sex symbol in the forties and Ozymandias
built a corporate empire selling action
figures of himself because of all the
real superheroes people lost interest in
superhero comics so comics about Pirates
are popular instead thanks to dr.
Manhattan technologies more advanced 80s
New York has electric cars and airships
and people eat a genetically modified
four-legged chicken in the 70s heroes
were outlawed so most of them retired
only Manhattan and the comedian are
allowed to keep working for the
government when the story starts tension
is rising in the cold war between
America and Russia everyone fears a
nuclear annihilation
the Doomsday clock approaches midnight
and the comedian is mysteriously killed
the mode is investigated by Rorschach a
hero who refused to retire on the
surface Rorschach is like Batman he
lurks in the shadows beats up criminals
says edgy [ __ ] in a gravelly voice but
by day Batman is Bruce Wayne
sexy genius billionaire while Rorschach
is Walter Kovacs a greasy loner Widow
who walks the streets with a sign that
says the end is nigh because
realistically the sort of person who
dresses up and fights people at night
isn't a functional person he's a nutcase
so Rorschach is an a social violent
psycho with an extreme worldview he
thinks all of society is filthy and
sinful and doesn't deserve mercy
Rorschach's black and white mask
reflects his black and white morality
everything's either good or evil and
evil must be punished he says he never
compromises me in his judgment but he's
often biased he spares people punishment
for personal reasons and like when he
hears the comedian tried to rape Silk
Spectre he doesn't care because he sees
the comedian as a patriot and Silk
Spectre as a [ __ ] Rorschach is
psychologically disturbed by sex as a
kid his mother was abusive and he saw
her working as a prostitute sexuality
reminds her or shack of his hatred and
disgust for his mother and he expresses
this anger by fighting criminals
Rorschach became a vigilante when he
heard about kitty Genovese a real-world
murder victim in the sixties Rorschach
was still a kind of rational person back
then until he discovered the savage
murder of a child Rorschach saw the
darkest side of humanity and a broke him
convinced him that the world is random
and godless and has no meaning save what
we choose to impose the only way
Rorschach could save himself from
despair and trauma was to impose his
brutal ideology punishing evil no matter
the cost which often just causes more
suffering like he routinely gets
information by breaking random people's
fingers until he hears something useful
he terrorizes a sick old man and
breaks into people's houses and eats all
their beans rorschach calls everyone
else parasites but he's the one who
lives off other people Rorschach calls
everyone filth but he's the one who
stinks he says he never compromises but
he often does and his obsession with
punishing evil just leaves more bloody
footprints behind him so Watchmen goes
deep into the psychology of the masked
Avenger and it doesn't find a cool hero
like Batman Rorschach is a gross
hypocritical sad broken man but
Rorschach does help uncover a conspiracy
that threatens millions of people the
dr. Manhattan explores what it means to
be superhuman he can effortlessly shape
the world around him on an atomic scale
he can teleport walk on the Sun sees
past present and future as one he's like
a god but he's a really shitty boyfriend
because being superhuman makes it hard
for him to relate with people he doesn't
have human needs or human fears he's
cold and distant and really bad at sex
Manhattan can see the universe from the
dance of atoms to ancient Martian
geology so humans are like ants to him
their lives are so small and short the
people around him age and die but he
never changes when he starts
relationships he already sees the future
when they'll break up through the medium
of comics we get to see time as
Manhattan does with past present and
future all visible at once like a story
with a predetermined end
Manhattan says that free will is an
illusion that were all puppets and he's
just a puppet who can see the strings so
in a way the most powerful being in the
universe is powerless Manhattan can't
change the future because to him it's
already happened Manhattan's superhuman
perspective makes him not human and
without human feelings he has no desire
to be a superhero and save the world
so Manhattan is a deconstruction of
characters like Superman suggesting that
a superhuman would actually not be a
great protector of humans
there's something existentially terrif
about a being so powerful he makes
regular humans irrelevant obsolete
like Neanderthals replaced by sapiens a
Manhattan gets falsely accused of giving
people cancer and his girlfriend Laurie
leaves him for an owl man
so Manhattan [ __ ] off the mouse and
builds a sandcastle eventually Laurie
convinces Manhattan that human life does
have value because of its sheer
miraculous improbability and that by the
way is a real actual smiley face on Mars
so Manhattan returns to Earth to try to
prevent apocalypse Nite Owl is a retired
hero back in the day he dressed like an
owl and used gadgets to fight crime but
now he finds that stuff embarrassing
he realized that punching criminals
doesn't actually make the world better
and all the costumes and gadgets were a
childish fantasy so now Nite Owl is just
dan dreiberg he's in his forties he
gained weight and he's not happy
Rorschach warns him of a conspiracy and
the threat of war but Dan feels
powerless to face these dangers he feels
lonely and useless and impotent he wants
to be with Laurie but he's awkward and
unconfident when they try to have sex
dan can't get it up there's something
missing from his life until Dan and
Laurie rediscovered the excitement of
being heroes they get back into costume
and spring Rorschach from jail and the
power and danger and fun of it sparks
magic in their relationship and being an
owl really gets dan's deer card so
superheroes are silly and childish but
they still have meaning dan writes an
essay about ornithology the scientific
study of birds and he says that
sometimes science loses the beauty and
poetry of nature and there's no point in
life if you're all sensible and rational
all the time we need wonder and romance
and silliness because it's fun and it
brings people together dan and Laurie
fall in love and embrace their heroic
identities and face the looming threat
of nuclear war Laurie is the most normal
person among the superheroes probably
because she never really wanted to be a
superhero
her mother Sally
was the original Silk Spectre and she
pushed lorry into being still expected
to making a train for a hero career like
one of those beauty pageant moms Laurie
hates the comedian because the comedian
had once tried to rape her mother Sally
but Laurie discovers that later on Sally
loved the comedian anyway and they had a
child together it turns out that the
comedian the most despicable character
in Watchmen is Lori's father so Laurie
smashes a bottle of nostalgia brand
perfume her childhood snow globe smashes
Manhattan's Martian Castle smashes
Laurie's whole idea of who she is
collapses becomes something Messier and
darker because she later plans to change
her costume into something similar to
the comedians it's as though she partly
embraces his legacy in the upcoming
Watchmen TV show Laurie takes the
comedian's surname Blake so this
revelation is a loss of innocence for
Laurie and for superheroes which is what
watchman's bloody smiley is all about
overall though Laurie's character isn't
explored as deeply as the other
characters she and her mother are
largely defined by their sexuality and
their relationships with men so
depictions of women is one comics trope
that Watchmen does little to subvert in
the end Laurie
Dan Manhattan and Rorschach discover a
conspiracy masterminded by Ozymandias
Ozymandias is Adrian Veidt another
retired hero said to be the smartest man
on earth
fate is a super ambitious super rich
super arrogant dude who wants to be like
Alexander the Great and like the
Egyptian pharaohs his dream is to unite
the world under his design fate realized
that superheroes couldn't save the world
from nuclear war so instead he hatched a
crazy plan he put a bunch of scientists
and artists on a secret island and
genetically engineered a giant psychic
squid monster he kills the comedian when
the comedian finds out his plan and he
uses a cancer hoax to get rid of
Manhattan and he frames Rorschach to get
him locked up and he hires an assassin
on himself to throw off suspicion and
finally he teleports the squid into New
York killing three million people to
make it look like aliens attacked to
scare the world into ending the Cold War
to unite humanity and bring peace on
earth
it's a crazy supervillain plan and it
actually succeeds America and Russia are
so freaked out by the supposed alien
that they make a peace deal as for
Rorschach and Manhattan and Dan and
Laurie they failed to prevent Ozymandias
killing millions so so much for
superheroes Ozymandias saves the world
not by punching anyone and not with
superhuman powers but by science and
determination and psychopathic
willingness to kill three million people
Ozymandias saves the world
at a terrible cost so is he a hero or a
villain throughout Watchmen there's a
comic book within the comic book a tale
of the black freighter it's a story
about a sailor who tries to save his
town from an apocalyptic pirate ship but
he ends up killing innocent people and
becoming just as evil as what he tried
to prevent noble intentions led him to
atrocity just like Ozymandias his plan
at the end of Watchmen Ozymandias has a
dream of the black freighter and his
last panel shows him alone separate from
the rest of the world because like the
Sailor
he is marooned from the rest of humanity
because of the evil he did but
Ozymandias says that someone had to take
the weight of that awful necessary crime
this pose looks kinda like the
crucifixion of Christ and we later see
an ad for the Tarkovsky movie the
sacrifice in which a man sacrifices
everything he loves to prevent war maybe
you can see Ozymandias plan as a heroic
self-sacrifice he did the terrible
necessary crime so that no one else had
to orb you can say he's just a
delusional eager maniacal mass murdering
psychopath and a criticism of rich All
Souls having way too much power in the
world in the first place does Ozymandias
really care about saving people or is he
just serving his pride and ambition
philosophically Ozymandias plan is
utilitarian he kills three million
people to save the entire world so he is
good outweighs his evil but Rorschach
doesn't believe in moral gray area he
sees just black and white so he wants to
reveal the truth of Ozymandias crimes to
punish him
even though revealing the truth of the
alien hoax would destroy the New World
Peace Rorschach says he will never
compromise not even in the face of
Armageddon
so Manhattan kills Rorschach to keep the
secret and in his final moment Rorschach
takes off his mask and dies as Walter
Kovacs showing his humanity and
vulnerability in the end cos deep down
under the anger Rorschach's just a
broken man who's craved death from the
start
Rorschach's inflexible morals can't
survive in a morally complex world and
it seems that his black and white
morality fails except we see earlier
that Rorschach wrote notes about
Ozymandias conspiracy and he sent them
to a journalist who may or may not
reveal the truth to the world the last
line of Watchmen is I leave it entirely
in your hands so when you close the
comic book in your hands you decide what
the ending means maybe Ozymandias hoax
is revealed
maybe Rorschach was right and Ozymandias
deserves punishment even if it risks
nuclear war or maybe you believe in
Ozymandias brave new world even though
it's built on murder and lies or maybe
you feel like dr. Manhattan he decides
that humans are too annoying and
complicated so he leaves the galaxy to
create life elsewhere in the end there's
no place for a superhuman among humans
or maybe you relate to Dan and Laurie
dan and Laurie don't save the world or
die for a noble cause but they do get a
happy ending they fall in love take new
identities and start a life together
planning to continue being superheroes
they know that being heroes doesn't
achieve much they know it's childish and
dangerous but they embrace the fun and
romance of it Watchmen is a criticism of
the fantasy of the superhero showing
that reality
is darker and more complicated than we
like to admit but despite that Dan and
Laurie's story reminds us that for all
of fantasies flaws it brings joy and
meaning to people's lives
the smiley is bloodied the snowglobe
broken the perfume smashed millions died
we grew up but we can still have
nostalgia for simpler times
in the end Watchmen is a Rorschach test
everyone has a different interpretation
of the story depending on which
characters and ideas resonate with you
it's entirely in your hands comment
below if you want more watchmen content
on old shift x there is a watchman TV
show coming out soon
there are also adaptations of his Dark
Materials dune and Lord of the Rings
coming and we'll make videos about some
of these series so now's a good time to
listen to these audiobooks you can get
any of these for free right now by
signing up for trial with audible
members get an audiobook each month and
if you cancel you keep the audiobooks
you can listen in the car or the gym or
in your Antarctic base with your
genetically engineered cat all of these
are classics and you won't regret
checking them out so sign up at
audible.com slash ASX thanks for
watching thanks to patrons Esther ole
Andrew Bronfman nasty Louis Mazur at
cave fish - and Arthur Dayne Cheers
you